Rachel's with us in Maryland welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Rachel hi Dave so I
have a question about student loans okay
student loans from graduate school and I
wasn't sure if it was if it's like three
times my mortgage did it be in the debt
snowball and step number two or should
it be like that I should be paying off
my mortgage once I get to that step and
then my loan
how much did student loan debt do you
know so it's from medical school so the
problem is I let it accrued Oh too much
but it's bertok in like three hundred
forty thousand so you're a doc yeah I'm
a PA I'm gonna Sedition assistant but
yeah so I have allotted a lot of them my
mortgage is 172 and what do you my so
right now I'm part-time but I'm a fifty
thousand why in the world are you
part-time so my my husband makes about a
hundred and forty a year but we have
four kids and we don't live near family
everyone's on the west coast so you know
in terms of we do carpool to the two
most that we can but in order to do a
nine-to-five most places you know
extended daycare close at five o'clock
there's no way for me to get to the kids
on time while they're this little once
they're in school whole times and it's
much easier but just for the time being
temporarily this is kind of where we're
holding three and forty thousand dollars
or student loan back I know so the brown
income based repayment right now it's a
cruise the rent so is it worth it to
wait twenty five years like they say and
let it be forgiven so that's what that's
what they say with federal loans if you
do the income based repayment after 25
years the loans are forgiven I don't
know what state the government will be
in at that point but I've you know like
21 more years to go is that worth the
tweezer first
if I try to pay this off and I'm unable
to pay for retirement at all so that's
my that's Ragan know I spent three
hundred forty thousand dollars to make
fifty hey how old are your babies seven
three and eighteen months and a baby
infant Wow okay here's the thing you
desperately need to make some money to
pay this off and no you don't wait 21
years so what are you gonna do sacrifice
your entire freakin life and have no
life because you're just gonna surrender
to these student loans when you have
graduated as a PA no you're gonna use
the PA and you're gonna go make a bunch
of money by working your heinie off and
you're gonna pay these loans back as
soon as you possibly can now you're not
going to do it this year not with an 18
month old and a newborn and you're
probably not gonna do it next year but
and but I I'm not waiting until 21 years
goes by for you to have a life and I'm
not waiting probably not waiting until
all the kids are in school for you to
have a life you're gonna have to go
youyou made a mess and the only way
you're gonna clean up the mess is to
clean up the mess you have got to go get
some income coming in and you have the
ability to make 150,000 a year maybe 200
and you desperately need to do that as
soon as humanly possible no excuses and
I mean I get it that it's probably gonna
be a year and maybe two years before but
if you get a couple these kids in school
on a couple of them in a daycare your
butt's working you made 340 thousand
dollars worth of decisions that you've
got to clean up and Wow oh my goodness